militär 100 zentrum kaisersteinbruch zum
zweiten mal in diesem jahr freut man
sich über rottweiler sieben welten
bekommen heute der militär hundemarke
die sie offiziell zum militär hunden in
ausbildung machen 2017 als
verteidigungsminister schon einmal die
hunde taufe durchgeführt hat der heute
burgenländische landeshauptmann hans
peter trost besonderes werden
im kreise des militärs zu seinem krise
des heers im eine schwere aufgabe für
das terminal aida exit enochs und heiko
sie alle werden heute einfach an von
bundeskanzlerin brigitte bierlein und
verteidigungsminister thomas steininger
in den militärdienst befördert ich bin
das erste mal hier ist es wirklich
wirklich bemerkenswert dass man hier zu
sehen bekommt was sie hier leisten was
sie ausbilden was sie machen und freue
mich sehr dass so viele da man in ihrer
mannschaft und frauen schaffte ich das
so sagen darf haben und es war ganz ganz
liebenswürdig von ihnen uns hier
einzuladen sondern uns große große
freude gemacht fielen dann kommt alles
erdenklich gute
viel erfahrung mit hundeerziehung haben
die experten der übergangsregierung
übrigens noch nicht sammeln können und
methode erzielen weniger da war ich
selber nur in der erziehung das kind
halten wir an einem tag die unterlaufen
schäfer und apropos hundeerziehung vor
fünf monaten im märz 2009 10 bei ihrer
taufe
hat das singen mittlerweile eingestellt
alles in allem eine veranstaltung ganz
nach plan
die faszination die von diesen welten
ausgeht ist nach wie vor ungebrochen
wenn wir es einmal berühren den jungen
welten in der hand zu haben
abgeschreckt zu werden und dadurch der
respekt wenn man steigert bei den
älteren hunden der respekt
welche aufgaben die dann erfüllen können
die grundausbildung dauert ein jahr
danach entscheidet sich wer spür
rettungs jagdschutz oder spezial und
wird
[Musik]